e
[Música]
as sementes são
precursoras da produção vegetal
bom e nós nosso país o Brasil
ele é o primeiro do mundo ele é
considerado o celeiro do mundo por
termos abundância se vegetativas e solos
profundos que são acolhedores para essa
semente de mostrarem sua potência
vegetativa porque é para isso que a
semente nasceu para mostrar sua potência
vegetativa
Ah e assim como a semente precisa de um
ambiente fértil para se desenvolver e
mostrar toda sua potência vegetativa eu
acredito que todos nós que estamos aqui
somos uma semente e viemos ao mundo para
mostrar a nossa potência para frutificar
é mas infelizmente nem todos têm um
ambiente fértil de desenvolvimento
e deixa-me contar só um ambiente fértil
onde eu cresci e onde eu estou Hoje
Sou brasileiro mas precisamente do Sul
Oi meu povo
56 por cento do país se autodeclara
negro
nós porém somos o último país a abolir a
escravidão
e são 133 anos de liberdade é o meus
bisavós e bisavós
temos mais tempo quando como país
escravista do que como República
é a chance de um jovem Preto morreu na
nossa cidade é muito maior do que o
jovem branco os dados de 2011 do
Ministério da Saúde diz que mais de
setenta por cento dos jovens mortos 2011
seja no tráfico seja na violência
policial
e eram jovens pretos e não só a
violência física é o que assola esse
público mas também outros fatores como
depressão falta de escolas descaso da
Saúde Pública
Ah e por muitas questões do filme me
perguntando
Hum será que ser preto é o que me limita
a mostrar a minha potência é sociedade
Será que a minha etnia é uma barreira de
desenvolvimento
E aí tem dia que não
o vídeo aqui o solo que nos foi
estruturado é uma herança colonial é um
solo infértil e assim como ele foi
construído ele foi estruturado Eu
acredito que a gente pode desconstruir e
construir um cenário melhor
é mas eu te pergunto
e quais são os elementos essenciais para
o solo fértil
Tá bom
eu tenho algumas
há sugestões como engenheiro agrônomo
eu quero
mostrar... Importantes para um solo
fértil
é um solo profundo bem adubado só Iago
e o meu solo foi a minha mãe
a
equação de toda a mãe preta
o Everson filho no camburão aí vai seu
filho Não traz não
é o sonho de da mãe preta a ver seu
filho no sucesso seja qual for essa
definição de sucesso e minha mãe ela
sofria violência quando eu tinha seis
meses de idade
oi e ela fugiu de casa para que eu não
cresci naquele ambiente de
desenvolvimento infértil
e ela queria que eu tivesse um ambiente
mais amoroso e seguro ela falava para
mim muito que eu tinha que estudar que
eu tinha que expor a minha inteligência
ela sem falar que era muito inteligente
Sabe de uma coisa eu acreditei não
é porque eu sou em toda a mãe preta é
ver seu filho no seu ápice do Sucesso
é
mas infelizmente Nem todas as vezes tem
uma mãe que tá ir lá te dar um apoio né
de dentro desse processo de
descobrimento eu ficava me perguntando
qual é o meu lugar no mundo aqui eu vim
você já se perguntou sobre isso
E aí o que entende que o mundo é do
tamanho do meu conhecimento
bom E cada vez que eu fui avançando no
meu conhecimento com a vez que eu fui
quebrando as barreiras e tabus que essa
cidade me colocava
onde aqui não há lugar para você aqui
não é acho que não é isso o teu caminho
eu fui meio que
esquecendo isso eu fui tapando os meus
ouvidos para negatividade e falando que
eu vou estar aonde eu quero estar
eu
entrei na graduação ganhei bolsa
mas somente a bolsa não foi suficiente
para me manter na faculdade é porque nem
só de bolsa vive estudante a gente
precisa de locomoção alimentação
xerox
e algumas barreiras foram colocando
assim poxa estar aqui na faculdade é o
meu lugar
os boletos chegam as contas chegam eu
não consigo só me dedicar os estudos
e Deus agronomia também estava me
perguntando Será que não abre um negócio
eu tenho espaço para mim
então acabamos entendendo que o solo é
importante a fertilidade do solo é
importante mas a planta também precisa
de sol para energizar
eu e o meu sol foi a professora Roseli a
coordenadora do curso de agronomia
porque no segundo ano de curso eu ia
desistir eu cheguei levei todo mundo
documentação e falei professora não
quero mais mas ela falou assim para mim
Lucas você é um dos nossos melhores
alunos
se você tem um lugar sim no agronegócio
Você tem uma potência ser
exposta aqui ó
eu e ela me ajudou a conseguir um
emprego contraturno ela me orientou ela
não tinha obrigação nenhuma
de fazer isso mas ela quis porque ela é
uma pessoa que ilumina
a 2019 e acabou sofrendo um acidente e
nos deixou
mas é preciso que uma pessoa só morre
quando ela esquecida
enquanto eu estiver aqui enquanto outras
pessoas que ela ajudou estiverem vivas
ela também permanece vivo
e ela me mostrou Agricultura Familiar
Universo multicultural de europeus não
herdeiros de Africanos indígenas e
mestiços
universo que setenta por cento dos
alimentos que estão na nossas mesas dos
brasileiros vêm da Agricultura Familiar
vem de mãos de produtoras e produtores
familiares porém somente 34 por cento do
PIB brasileiro chega até esses atores
produtores e eu fiquei me questionando
isso tá em justo como que eu como
engenheiro agrônomo eu posso criar
ambientes e fertilidade Desenvolvimento
Social para esses produtores para essas
produtores
eu
fui aí então que eu entendi que as
plantas não precisa não só de um solo e
de sol as altas de água também
e a minha água foi meu propósito de
gerar prosperidade Agricultura Familiar
por meio da digitalização
durante a minha caminhada trajetória me
tornei programador
o e construir soluções digitais para
melhorar a vida do homem do campo da
mulher do Campo
E aí dentro desse processo do meu
caminho empreendedor
eu entendi que eu não queria empreender
somente por empreender Eu queria um
empreender isso com propósito Eu queria
que eu queria empreendedorismo com
impacto social
em frente ao que cirurgia cultivando o
meu negócio social hoje nós atuamos com
a gestão pública e mostrando como é
possível criar ambientes parte de
desenvolvimento da Agricultura Familiar
e esse processo de Startup os negócios
sociais ecossistema de inovação atrair
muitos parceiros empresas nacionais e
multinacionais a investirem na minha
ideia que antes era uma ideia hoje é
concretizado
e todo esse investimento resultou na
inclusão produtiva do homem da mulher do
campo nós geramos emprego geramos renda
geramos legalidade tiramos produtores da
clandestinidade e colocamos ele sem
profissionalismo condições de dignidade
como eles merecem
e a metodologia tá cultivando coloca
sempre a família produtora no centro e
mostra os parceiros da entorno como isso
é possível como é possível criar
ambientes de desenvolvimento
e esse ambiente de desenvolvimento se
expressam em 15 tonelada de alimentos
para a merenda escolar o aumento do ICMS
para a gestão pública
agilidade na legalização E também o
aumento no faturamento das
agroindústrias
é
mas é tudo isso que eu falei para você
hoje
e o que que eu quero que você leve
e são questões que não é somente o
quanto eu sou bom no que eu faço mas não
uma reflexão quantos Lucas felipes hoje
estão na periferia
quantas Lucas Felipe hoje eles estão
morrendo
Ah e não tiver a oportunidade não tiver
uma praça de mamãe não tiveram apoio do
professor
bom e como que a gente pode mudar isso
que adubos estamos utilizando na nossa
sociedade
para
cultivar ou melhorar esse solo
Oi gente continuar a do bando nosso solo
com racismo com desigualdade com
intolerância com feminicídio com fome
E é só isso que a gente vai cultivar É
só isso que é só isso que esse solo pode
nos oferecer
Mas eu acredito assim como minha mãe
falava que eu era inteligente Eu
acredito que a sociedade pode ser muito
melhor do que isso
e a gente pode desconstruir muitas
coisas e a do bar convida respeito
Desenvolvimento Social empatia dignidade
Equidade inclusão
porque nós somos melhores que isso
o personalizar
e eu queria trazer uma reflexão e também
uma curiosidade
é desse dessa semente vegetal
é muito incrível que as câmeras
e Tem um ditado arabe e.t. fala que Quem
planta tâmaras não colhe sabe porque o
ciclo vegetativo da Tâmara
desde a sua implantação até o primeiro
fruto é de 100 anos
O que é sobre isso que eu quero trazer
para gente encerrar
porque hoje para eu estar aqui
conversando com vocês alguém perguntou
essa câmera que era educação para jovens
pretos inclusão bolsas cotas
é claro que não ele Talvez o resultado
de imediato Não era isso que ele tava
esperando essa pessoa que plantar essa
câmera
é mas quando alguém pensa em contar uma
câmera que ela não vai kohler é uma
pessoa que entendeu o que ia ser humano
o que nós sobre mim
e não é sobre você é sobre nós
Porque nós que a gente não vai colher os
frutos das ações que a gente fizer hoje
seja uma campanha do agasalho seja uma
cesta básica
Olá sejam cursinho pré-vestibular
gratuito
é mas é preciso a gente plantar essas
câmeras
bom e se você me questionar assim mas
Lucas Que tipo de câmera você sugere que
o plant
a hora
é um sinto muito a uma câmera importante
de ser implantado um me perdoe é uma
câmera é importante de ser plantado um
eu te amo ah uma câmera é importante de
ser plantada eu sou grato
é porque a gratidão é um lugar a gente
entende que
tudo que nós crescemos como humanidade
até hoje não foi somente no
individualismo não foi no individualismo
É mas no coletivo foi no Ubuntu da
empatia
Oi e para finalizar eu queria agradecer
a todas as pessoas que por um segundo
pensaram me ajudar e me ajudar na minha
trajetória atingir meu Ápice como ser
humano bom obrigado
E aí